The Joe Rogan Experience I don't know
anything but I've been watching oh dude
on the plane I was watching the [__]
I've been watching the Ken Burns Vietnam
heavy stuff God damn dude I cried on the
plane like a [__] idiot oh is that
why you watched PBS stock
Mark if you're gonna say nasty stuff
that's pretty funny that was a nice ride
though I can remember when the Vietnam
War ended really yeah I was a little kid
I was living in San Francisco and I
remember thinking thank God we're never
going to do War again but thank God it's
over while I'm a child I remember
thinking that yeah
boy they're glad they figured this out
that was long it was nine years dude
from day one they were like we're not
gonna win yeah from day one McNamara's
in there with LBJ like this isn't going
this is never gonna work yeah they just
kept doing it a lot of heroin out there
oh my God
[Music]
while watching this I like drunk texted
my uncle who got wounded in Vietnam I
was like where'd you get hurt
it's like a crazy text to send oh my God
and then he explained how he got hurt
and it was like whoa I went to the house
he was uh he was a forward Observer for
his group it was the Battle of [__] I'll
find it but uh it was 200 U.S soldiers
surrounded by about 3 000 Vietcong or
rvn and then
uh he was the Ford Observer that was
calling in coordinates so they were all
trying to get him he would they got him
they hit him with an RPG eventually but
he was he was the one up front calling
in the gunships calling the artillery
where to go and right oh yeah yeah wow
like a spotter and crew yeah there he is
the sun right I'm just asking
Drang Valley incident
1965. Googled Gillis Vietnam no his last
name's not Gillis ah
what's crazy is the Vietnamese don't
even hate Americans no they hate the
Chinese way more that shit's all past
them who doesn't they call the the
American war and not they uh it was uh
the Battle of Hill 102 AKA The Battle of
caisson Valley
65 Americans killed
200 Americans surrounded by 2 000.
but then I was a little buzzed I'm
asking [__] up questions like what's
it like what's it like a broadest
question he said what happens is you
enter a Zone where you just shut down
your emotions and focus on what you need
to do to survive and protect your man no
time to process feelings there's
enormous chaos but you were acutely
aware of everything at least that was my
experience wow this is a wild response
yeah you said at one point there were
waves of MVA running towards us but my
sole Focus was to stop them from getting
too close with a gunship known as spooky
I mowed them down as they Advanced
without the Relentless stream of fire
from spooky we would have been overrun
thank God for spooking damn wow gunship
saying fire to this area I was talking
he said I was the Ford Observer so my
job was to keep artillery jet strikes
and gunship fire raining down the enemy
does he want you reading this on air
he'll be all right that's why they were
trying to get through me and take me out
which they eventually did but I took a
lot of them out first
drinking watching the documentary on my
phone like damn I'm gonna join with that
guy on a porch just sounds cool I'll
tell you he's my my other uncle was in
Vietnam and was like uh it's the gunship
there it is spooky yeah wow my other
uncle was in Vietnam and he never talks
about it yeah that guy who if you ask
he's they down spooky look at that
ouch
1968 February 15th nine killed and
Downing of spooky gunship to The Spook
to the spooky spooky cheers spooky wow
what a [__] up war that was I think
zagora's Dad was a nom was it a terrible
[__] dumb War silly wasted time not
only a dumb more but a dumb war that was
uh that came about because of a false
flag
talking yeah golfer talking they lied
about an incident to try to get us into
the war yeah it's [__] great that's
like what we're talking about before
with false [__] time it really
happened it did they used to do them all
the time what'd you say
it's like that's that's what I did yeah
they 100 would lesser known fact to Jim
Morrison's father Captain George Stephan
Morrison commanded the carrier division
during the Gulf of Tonkin incident CIA
the Gulf of Tonkin incident famously
gave the Johnson Administration the
justification they needed to escalate
the Vietnam War J.R.R token wow it's his
dad imagine that and your dad becomes
Break On Through the other side I know
that's why he went so counterculture
your son rather becomes that yeah the
music they're playing in the [__]
helicopters
great music great dude the 60s was the
best music so what did your what did
your uncle do to like what was it like
when he came back I think he came back
and
he had a very stressful job well they do
[__] it I'll it's pretty once I tell you
what he did it's specific
[__] Forrest Gump dude he was in
Three Mile Island he was at the World
Trade Center he was in Vietnam's
[__] he's [__] what it was
everywhere he's an incredible story but
connect the dots shrimp fish I think I
was reading an article about it because
he's pretty popular and he was uh
he was describing how his job was very
stressful because he worked in like Wall
Street and he thought he was like
blaming all his stress on Wall Street
then it was like clearly it was you got
hit with a [__] RPG and almost died
yikes and you mowed people down in
Vietnam and then he went back to Vietnam
and saw it and was like oh this is all
all of my problems all right he went
back what went to exactly where he was
away yeah imagine getting out and going
back what a nightmare I think he said he
was he felt bad because he got wounded
pretty severely like his calf got blown
off he's missing a nipple he got drilled
he's Miss Pat you got
uh but he was like I was too Reckless
and now I'm not with my men and he he
held that against himself was he a drug
addict and whatnot I don't know about
drugs for sure well that's too Reckless
he was like I was too Reckless I [__]
that up now I'm not with my men because
he was like holding that against himself
and then he saw what happened and where
he was and he was like this of course I
got wounded yeah it was they were coming
after people shooting at me yeah they
knew I was the guy calling in the
airstrikes blew his calf off yeah his
legs he's literally missing his [__]
calf poof nipples off yeah cap in half
I can't even have
to he can't help himself
Super Bowl calf time
show we saw it yeah we were there on
shrooms Rihanna
shot him
Ariana
I can do I can do a little bit of you I
take it off yeah I could try go nuts
apparently was like one of the most
amazing places to visit I loved it yeah
yeah
Ho Chi Minh Ho Chi Minh that's what they
call it and then I went to the South to
like some Tiny Town and away from like
Backpackers I was getting sick of
everybody
you get sick of all the [__] tourists
whites yeah district one of Ho Chi Minh
is like it's like TGI Friday it's
whatever yeah they have the the war
remnants Museum it's the Vietnam War
Memorial Museum and they have a GI
outside he was like it's all propaganda
in there whoa cause he just talked about
the Senators who later came out and said
said like oh yeah I killed like 50
innocent people yeah what was that there
was one Center that he was there was you
know they were applauding him as a war
hero and then finally he just like said
I have to come clean yeah I got some
[__] I don't remember that he's like I
raped a bunch of people killed a bunch
of innocent people we just went down and
mowed out and he was like running on the
fact that he's a hero and then he's like
yeah when Jamie comes back we'll uh
figure out that cam Burns that Ken Burns
Vietnam though is [__] wild I tried
to watch it the first time I've watched
like it was it is dense yeah then once
you get into it it's like God damn was
it 12 hours
great for flights yeah uh and the
pandemic yeah the Bobby sandwich there
is amazing yeah the fresh bread they got
that from the French what's it called
bon me bomb me yeah
God what I remember is that it was just
every day was a war
what about the foe over there pretty
good pho's not bad I was really into the
bottomies all right you just get him to
go they're so good so fresh
um
it's a fresh bread they love it French
bread yeah so we eat Po Boys on
the French is without the bread it's not
a po boy yeah so I loved one of those
things of like somebody at some college
campus was like bitching at their
student uh Union for doing the um
doing the bonami sandwich not the
authentic way like some sort of Tabasco
on it or something instead of like
Sriracha yeah he's like that's not
authentic Vietnamese everyone's like
it's french bread
it's from the colonization did you guys
ever do the stand up bong hit you know
some paper towel roll you're on the on
the wall and you're both squatting and
he takes a giant vaporizer hit or
whatever and he blows it into your mouth
while you stand up and then you fall
back down immediately no you never did
that no oh oh oh beer bong no no weed
huge hit and then
as you come up and it hits you so hard
as you're standing up as you're standing
up so the uh the oxygen goes away well
interesting this is pre-internet you
know yeah four guys in a house just
figuring [__] out figuring it out
nothing to do if I blow smoke in your
face yeah and then you stand up that was
one of the things they did during Nam
they do it through rifles yeah
that's cool that can't end well yeah no
they're good yeah yikes shot that hasn't
been high as [__] and also in Vietnam in
the middle of the war going what the
[__] man yeah so they they did a shotgun
where they literally opened up the
barrel damn
and then blowing the weed through I like
how they're not touching it with their
mouth because they don't want to get
herpes
they don't want to be gay they don't be
sucking on that gun in front of
everybody whoa
yeah
like super paranoid and high as [__] and
you're in the jungle in Vietnam yeah you
realize you're a stupid [__] war that
makes no sense has zero support behind
it the nature walks are good what are we
doing I'm shooting people with zero
support behind it yeah you're out in
nature yeah that's what they said one of
the reasons they won they took over all
the reasons of Vietnam won they were
like the Americans are like I don't even
want to be here well yeah no one did
yeah like I don't care about these
people well the Vietnamese are fighting
for their home what about they ever meet
one of those guys who's like you know
when 9 11 happened they're like I'm
going over there yeah thank you for guys
like that yeah thank you I'm gonna stay
here Tillman left being a [__] NFL
star to go over there and he got killed
by friendly fire oh yeah and they had to
hide it they had to hide it no he was a
hero he was that and he wasn't a hero
obviously he was just still a hero a
bummer of a guy like a bad guy no no no
no no no no it was an accident I thought
they were like some people said it was
wrong some people say it was on purpose
like sometimes you start to see like oh
this is [__] pointless what are we
doing here even and then like oh we
gotta shut them up oh no
is ethereum boy I hope not yeah God you
hope not yeesh anyway let's talk about
something funnier
I'm in Friendly Fire that's almost
Vietnam I know right
you changed the mood of everything when
you read out your uncle's texture I mean
imagine being on a plane reading it the
way he described it to is amazing yeah
you're all smart yeah he's fired up